Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. There was a man named Ulf, son of Bialf, and Halbera, daughter of Ulf the Fearless. She was sister of Halbjorn, half-giant in Hrafnister, and he the father of Ketel Heng. Ulf was a man so tall and strong that none could match him, and in his youth he roved the seas as a freebooter. In fellowship with him was one Kari of Berdla, a man of renown for strength and daring. He was a berserker. Ulf and he had one common purse and were the dearest friends. So begins Egil's saga, one of the best known of all the Icelandic sagas. Set in the 9th century but written down, as we'll discover much later,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。曾有一个人名叫乌尔夫（Ulf），是比亚尔夫（Bialf）之子，哈尔贝拉（Halbera）无畏者乌尔夫之女。她是哈尔比约恩（Halbjorn）的妹妹，后者是哈夫尼斯泰尔（Hrafnister）的半巨人，而哈尔比约恩则是凯特尔·亨格（Ketel Heng）的父亲。乌尔夫身材高大、力大无穷，无人能敌，年轻时曾在海上当海盗。与他结交的是贝德拉（Berdla）的卡里（Kari），此人以力量和胆识闻名。他是一名狂战士。乌尔夫和他共用一个钱袋，是挚友。这便是《埃吉尔萨加》（Egil's saga）的开篇，它是所有冰岛萨加中最为著名的一部。故事背景设定在9世纪，但正如我们稍后将发现的，它被文字记录下来是在很久之后，
it plunges us into a world of Vikings and shipwrights, kings and poets, blood feuds and shapeshifters. Tom Holland, it sounds like a production meeting from The Rest Is History. It does indeed. What are you, king, poet, berserker, troll? I think all of them. I think that's true.
它把我们带入了维京人和造船匠、国王与诗人、血亲复仇与变形人的世界。汤姆·霍兰，听起来像是《历史的余烬》的制作会议。确实如此。你是什么，国王、诗人、狂战士还是巨魔？我想全都是。我想确实如此。
I love Egil's saga because it features Athelstan. Yes, it does. I think all of them. I think that's true. I love Egil's Saga because it features Athelstan. Yes, it does. I thought we'd get to that. Yeah. So there's sort of bits of history that float into these things, aren't there? Now, you are doing this on location, effectively. I'm literally in Norway. Yeah, amazing.
我喜欢《埃吉尔萨加》是因为它里面有埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）。是的，确实有。我想全都是。我想确实如此。我喜欢《埃吉尔萨加》是因为它里面有埃塞尔斯坦。是的，确实有。我猜到我们会聊到这个。是啊。所以这些故事里会融入一些历史片段，对吧？现在，你基本上是在实地进行录制。我真的在挪威。是啊，太棒了。
I'm literally in Norway. I'm in the basement of a university department in Oslo. Such a glamorous life you lead. Yeah, it is. And I'll tell you how glamorous it is, is that as I'm saying this, I'm being photographed by Julia, who is a photographer from...
我真的在挪威。我在奥斯陆一所大学部门的地下室里。你过着多么光鲜亮丽的生活啊。对，确实如此。我来告诉你这有多光鲜亮丽，就在我说话的时候，朱莉娅（Julia）正在给我拍照，她是一位来自……
Norwegian Vogue? Norwegian newspaper. Norwegian Vogue. Well, so the rest of history is absolutely massive in Norway. People keep rushing up to me saying, are you the rest of history's Dominic Sandbrook? And when they find out, I'm not. Huge disappointment. But Julia, do you want to just absolutely i skulle bara si hej till alle de
挪威《Vogue》？挪威报纸。挪威《Vogue》。好吧，所以《历史的余烬》在挪威绝对是大受欢迎。人们不断跑来对我说：“你是《历史的余烬》的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克吗？”当他们发现我不是时，极其失望。但是朱莉娅，你想不想对大家说一声“你好”（i skulle bara si hej till alle de）
norske littera so there you go wow what was that it was it was a hello to everybody oh that's very nice that's very nice hello julia it's always good to have a guest star on the podcast isn't it but we have another guest star do we we do We do. We have a real guest star. So a few years ago, I went to Iceland on holiday, which I heartily recommend. Tom, you must have been to Iceland. I have. I've been on a cricket tour to Iceland. Oh, of course.
挪威读者（norske littera）……所以你看，哇，刚刚那是什么？那是向所有人问好，噢，那太好了，那太好了。你好，朱莉娅，播客里总是有个特邀嘉宾挺不错的，对吧？不过我们还有另一个特邀嘉宾，是吗？我们有。我们确实有。我们有一个真正的特邀嘉宾。所以几年前，我去冰岛度假，我强烈推荐。汤姆，你一定去过冰岛。我去过。我去冰岛进行过板球巡回赛。哦，当然。
God almighty. And I actually wrote a Scaldic verse about it. Did you? Celebrating the defeat of the puffin eaters. I don't think anyone wants to hear about that. Do they? I don't. Anyway.
天哪。我还为此写了一首斯卡尔德诗（Scaldic verse）。是吗？为了庆祝战胜吃海雀的人。我想没人想听这个。对吧？我不想。总之。
Well, maybe you can put that on twitter and everybody can can read about it so i went to iceland and i took a book with me called beyond the northlands viking voyages and the old norse sagas an absolutely brilliant book beautifully illustrated a book about the vikings kind of world view and their sense of geography and their sense of all these kind of monsters and weird lands that were out there. And the author of that book is Eleanor Rosamund Barraclough from Durham University. And she's with us here today. Hello, Eleanor. Thank you for coming on the show. Hi, it's such a pleasure. I'm hoping that Tom's got some Scaldic verse in Old Norse to give us, otherwise that's it, I'm off. It's not in Old Norse, but I might dig it up for the second half.
好吧，也许你可以把它发到推特上，这样大家都能看到了。所以我去了冰岛，带了一本书，叫做《北境之外：维京航行与古诺斯萨加》（Beyond the Northlands: Viking Voyages and the Old Norse Sagas），这是一本绝对精彩的书，配有美丽的插图，讲述了维京人的世界观、地理观念，以及他们对当时存在的各种怪物和奇异大陆的认知。这本书的作者是来自达勒姆大学（Durham University）的埃莉诺·罗莎蒙德·巴拉克劳夫（Eleanor Rosamund Barraclough）。她今天和我们在一起。你好，埃莉诺。谢谢你来参加节目。嗨，非常荣幸。我希望汤姆能用古诺斯语念一首斯卡尔德诗给我们听，否则的话，我就要走了。这不是古诺斯语，但我可能会在下半场把它翻出来。
In fact, you know what, I'm going to do that. I'm going to dig it out and I'm going to quote it at the start of the second half so that's something for Dominic to look forward to yeah no I'm afraid it's in English all our listeners all our listeners will I mean they never desert us halfway through anyway but even if they're tempted they would they would stick around for that they'll be fleeing to Iceland so um Eleanor let's get into the subject. So Iceland, when do human beings first arrive in Iceland and where do they come from? That's a really good question. And it's not entirely clear because although we know more about the Scandinavian and British Isles settlement, it seems possible that actually there are holy men called Papa who are part of this peregrination
事实上，你知道吗，我要这么做。我要把它翻出来，并在下半场开始时引用它，所以这是多米尼克可以期待的事情。好吧，恐怕它是英文的，我们所有的听众，我们所有的听众，我的意思是他们反正也不会中途抛弃我们，但即使他们动了心，他们也会留下来看这个，他们会逃往冰岛。所以，埃莉诺，让我们切入正题。那么冰岛，人类是什么时候第一次抵达冰岛的？他们是从哪里来的？这是一个非常好的问题。目前还不完全清楚，因为尽管我们对斯堪的纳维亚和不列颠群岛的定居情况了解更多，但似乎有可能，实际上有一些被称为“帕帕”（Papa）的圣职人员参与了这次漫游
from possibly Ireland who are setting out this peregrination from possibly Ireland who are setting out across the North Sea trying to find little corners of the world, little islands where they can get a bit of peace and do some communing with God and nature. And it's possible that some of these end up in Iceland. There's a man called Dickwill who's in the Frankish kingdom. What's he called? Sorry, Dickwill. Dickwill. D-I-C-U-I-L got it if there's another way of pronouncing it that's gonna be really embarrassing because that's no wonder no wonder he fled to Iceland for the name like that well see he didn't even flee but he says that in around what is it 794 something like that so just after Lindisfarne gets gets attacked by by Vikings over off the
可能来自爱尔兰，他们开始从可能来自爱尔兰的地方展开这次漫游，横渡北海，试图寻找世界上安静的角落、可以获得一丝平静并与上帝和大自然交流的小岛。而其中一些人最终来到冰岛，这是有可能的。有一个人名叫迪克维尔（Dickwill），身处法兰克王国。他叫什么？对不起，迪克维尔。迪克维尔。D-I-C-U-I-L，明白了。如果还有另一种发音方式，那可就太尴尬了，因为难怪，难怪他会因为这样的名字而逃到冰岛。好吧，看，他甚至没有逃跑，但他说在公元794年前后，差不多那个时候，也就是林迪斯法恩（Lindisfarne）遭到诺森伯兰海岸外的维京人袭击后不久
Northumberland coast he gets visited by a group of papa these Irishmen who say that they went to the very far north to an island where it was so bright that even at mid-summer in the middle of the night they were able to pick lice off their clothes which also says something about their their general hygiene in this period so it's possible that's Iceland it's possible it's not you know they also got to Shetland or New Faroes but then we know a little bit more about the Scandinavian settlement so we have a few sources that start to be written down in Iceland in the 12th century and they describe how Iceland is settled predominantly from Norway and first in about yeah 860 or something like that someone gets blown off course there they come back someone else then decides to
他受到了一群“帕帕”的造访，这些爱尔兰人说他们去到了极北的一个岛屿，那里阳光如此明媚，以至于即使在仲夏的午夜，他们也能从衣服上挑出虱子，这也说明了他们这一时期的整体卫生状况。所以那可能是冰岛，也可能不是，你知道的，他们也可能去了设得兰群岛或法罗群岛。但随后我们对斯堪的纳维亚人的定居有了更多了解，我们在12世纪开始在冰岛被记录下来的少数文献来源中，得知了冰岛是如何主要由挪威人定居的。首先在大约公元860年左右，有人被风吹离了航线，他们回去了；然后另一个人决定
do a circumnavigation of of iceland someone else then stays there over winter but we're really talking around 871 that sort of era that that we start to get permanent settlement there this is what the later uh textual sources from iceland from medieval iceland tell us but what's really wonderful is that we also have evidence from the most Icelandic of sources, which is a volcano, which erupts around that time. Yeah. So the volcano erupts. We can date that volcano because we've got the ice cores from Greenland
环航冰岛；接着又有人在那里过冬。但我们真正讨论的是公元871年左右的那个时代，我们开始在那里有了永久定居点。这是中世纪冰岛后来的文字资料告诉我们的。但真正奇妙的是，我们也有来自最典型的冰岛源头的证据，那就是一座大约在那时爆发的火山。是的，所以火山爆发了。我们可以通过格陵兰岛的冰芯来为那座火山定居测年，
that also show up that same layer. So we know it's around 870, 871 or something. And then most of the settlement layers, the archaeological settlement layers from that first occupation period of Iceland are directly on top of that volcano. So we know it is around that time. There's a writer called Auri the Wise, and he's writing in Iceland, kind of like 1122, that sort of time. And he says there were papa there when the Icelanders first arrived, but they didn't want to stay there with a load of heathens and so they left. So who knows, it's possible that someone was there before, but that's when we're talking about the settlement of Iceland. We also know that there are lots of people from the British Isles
冰芯中也显示了同一火山灰层。所以我们知道大约是在公元870年、871年左右。然后，冰岛第一波占领时期的绝大多数定居层、考古定居层都直接压在那层火山灰之上。所以我们知道大约就是那个时期。有一位作家名叫“智者阿里”（Auri the Wise），他在公元1122年左右在冰岛写作，他说当冰岛人初次抵达时，那里有“帕帕”人，但他们不想和一大群异教徒呆在一起，于是便离开了。所以谁知道呢，可能之前就有人在那里，但这就是我们所说的冰岛定居时期。我们还知道有许多来自不列颠群岛的人
who come over, particularly the females. And that's something you can see in modern Icelanders' DNA, that there seems to be more Norwegian DNA in more of the male settlers or more male modern Icelanders and more DNA from the British Isles from modern Icelandic females. And are they being taken there as slaves? That's what I was going to ask. Well, that's the general perception. And certainly, we know there are a lot of slaves. And when we look at, again, later textual sources, a lot of the slaves have Irish-sounding names. So
渡海而来，尤其是女性。这是你在现代冰岛人DNA中可以看到的，似乎更多的挪威DNA存在于更多的男性定居者或更多的现代冰岛男性中，而更多来自不列颠群岛的DNA则存在于现代冰岛女性中。她们是被当作奴隶带过去的吗？这正是我要问的。嗯，这是普遍的看法。当然，我们知道有大量的奴隶。当我们再次查看后来的文字资料时，许多奴隶都有听起来像爱尔兰的名字。所以
yeah, there will be some of that. But we've also got to think that by that time in the British Isles and in Ireland, there are a lot of Norse settlers. And so it's possible that some of these Norse settlers are kind of mixing culturally with people who are going to sort of genetically look like they're, say, Irish or from British Isles. But culturally, they're going to be very much in that Norse cultural milieu. So, you know, yeah, it's hard. It's hard to tell, really, a bit of both. There was an Irish princess called Ord the Deep-Minded. Oh, sort of, sort of. So, yes. So, Eidr or Ord, or she's also known as Unnur the Deep-Minded, one of the first settlers of Iceland, according to the sagas. And certainly, she comes from a context of the British Isles.
是的，会有这方面的原因。但我们也必须考虑到，到那个时候，在不列颠群岛和爱尔兰，已经有很多诺斯定居者了。因此，其中一些诺斯定居者可能在文化上与那些在基因上看起来像是爱尔兰人或来自不列颠群岛的人进行融合。但在文化上，他们将非常契合那个诺斯文化圈。所以，是的，这很难说清楚，实际上两者兼而有之。曾有一位爱尔兰公主名叫“深谋远虑的奥德”（Ord the Deep-Minded）。哦，算是吧，算是吧。所以，是的。因此，厄德（Eidr）或奥德（Ord），她也被称为“深谋远虑的乌努尔”（Unnur the Deep-Minded），根据萨加斯的记载，她是冰岛最早的定居者之一。当然，她来自不列颠群岛的背景。
She's not a princess herself, but there is a saga, and I know we'll come back to the sagas later, called Laxdala Saga, the saga of people of Salmon Valley, literally, where there is a female slave who is brought to Iceland and ends up having a child there who becomes a very prominent saga character, a great hero. And she seems to be completely mute. And it's only that one day they hear her talking in Irish, essentially to her child. And it turns out she's not mute at all. She's just decided she doesn't want to talk. And she says, well, yes, I'm the daughter of one of the Irish kings. But, again, we're talking about a saga, and everything gets a bit pimped up and romanticised in the saga.
她自己不是公主，但有一个萨加——我知道我们稍后会回到萨加的话题——叫做《拉克斯达拉萨加》（Laxdala Saga），即字面意思上的“鲑鱼谷人的萨加”，其中有一个女奴被带到冰岛，最终在那里生了一个孩子，后来成了萨加中非常突出的角色、一位伟大的英雄。她似乎完全是个哑人。直到有一天，人们听到她实质上是在用爱尔兰语跟她的孩子说话。结果发现她根本不是哑巴。她只是决定自己不想说话。她说：“是的，我是爱尔兰国王之一的女儿。”但是，话又说回来，我们谈论的是一个萨加，而在萨加中，一切都会被夸大和浪漫化。
That's a good academic expression. So here's a question for you. I mean, a question that will occur to anyone who's been to Iceland. Why would you go to Iceland? I mean, it's very hard to grow anything. You know, the British Isles are kind of in the way, which are famously, you know, the lowlands of England, very fertile and all that. Why Iceland? Are you fleeing? Are you running away? Is that why you go? Again, depends who you ask. So again, if we look at the later textual sources coming from Iceland, they've got a very clear origin myth.
这是一个很好的学术表达。所以这里有一个问题要问你。我是说，任何去过冰岛的人都会产生的一个问题：你为什么要云冰岛？我是说，那里很难种植任何东西。你知道，不列颠群岛挡在前面，众所周知，英格兰的低地非常肥沃，诸如此类。为什么是冰岛？你在逃亡吗？你在逃跑吗？这就是你去的理由吗？同样，这取决于你问的是谁。所以，如果我们再次查看来自冰岛的后来的文字资料，它们有一个非常清晰的起源神话。
And what they say is the king of Norway was really tyrannical, wanted to take over all our lands, and that's Harald Fairhair. And so we decided to leave. We didn't want to be under his yoke. And so we went to Iceland. He's kind of seen as the Norwegians as their first king. Yeah. And he's becoming king basically at the same time
它们所说的是，挪威国王非常暴虐，想要夺取我们所有的土地，那个人就是“金发王”哈拉尔（Harald Fairhair）。因此我们决定离开。我们不想在他的统治下生活。所以我们去了冰岛。他被视为挪威人的第一位国王。是的。基本上，他成为国王的时间与
as the immigration is starting. Yeah, it's a little bit hazy. You know, the sources are all a bit dodgy, but yeah, pretty much. But you have to think about various things there. One of which is that by the time that these sagas, these texts are being written down, and again, I don't want to sort of talk about this too much
移民潮开始的时间差不多。是的，有点模糊。你知道，资料都有点靠不住，但是是的，差不多。但你必须考虑各种因素。其中之一是，当这些萨加斯、这些文本被写下来的时候——再说一次，我不想过多地讨论这个，
because I'm sure we'll come back to it, But we're talking about the 13th century in Iceland is very politically volatile. And there's a lot of outside interference from the Norwegian crown. So that's the perfect point where Icelanders are going to be trying to define themselves in opposition to that and say, look, we've always been independent, we've always been free. We've never been under the Norwegian yoke. In fact, we left Norway because of that. So you have to think, okay, maybe there's some truth there, but maybe there's something else going on that's more to do with the context in which those texts are being transmitted and written down. You have to also think that it might be as simple as people needing more land, people needing... and i mean iceland isn't isn't a terrible place to to try and grow some crops and and and uh you know keep keep farms and all the rest of it it is it's possible um
因为我确信我们会回过头来谈论它——但我们讨论的是13世纪的冰岛，当时政治局势非常动荡。挪威王室有很多外部干涉。这正是冰岛人试图通过与挪威王室对立来定义自己、并说“看，我们一直都是独立的，我们一直都是自由的，我们从未屈服于挪威的统治，事实上，我们就是因为这个才离开挪威的”的绝佳时机。所以你必须思考，好吧，也许其中有一些真相，但也许还有其他原因，这更多地与这些文本得以流传和记录的语境有关。你还得考虑到，原因可能很简单，就是人们需要更多的土地，人们需要……我的意思是，冰岛并不是一个糟糕到无法尝试种植庄稼、经营农场以及诸如此类的地方，这是有可能的，
so there's so presumably there there is only a finite amount of good land. And I guess it fills up quite quickly, does it? Exactly. And so again, what we're told is that within 60 years or so, so by around 930, Iceland is pretty much settled. All the good land has been taken, which, yeah, maybe true to some extent. Again, it's a nice, neat narrative. A nice, neat narrative is always problematic, right? But yeah, exactly. I mean, the problem with iceland and yeah dominic you might remember this i don't know how far you got but the the interior is really not very habitable at all there's nothing there right i mean you couldn't live there no no no it's mountains and glaciers and and few volcanoes knocking around and in the saga is an awful lot of trolls and other um strange creatures So we're talking really around the edge.
所以，据推测，优质土地是有限的。我猜它填满的速度相当快，对吧？正是如此。因此，再次说明，我们被告知在60年左右的时间里，也就是到930年左右，冰岛基本上就已经定居满了。所有好地都被占了，这在某种程度上也许是真的。同样，这是一个完美、整洁的叙事。一个完美、整洁的叙事总是成问题的，对吧？但是的，完全如此。我的意思是，冰岛的问题在于——多米尼克，你可能还记得这一点，我不知道你去了多远——内陆地区确实非常不适宜居住，那里什么都没有，对吧？我的意思是，你根本无法在那里生活。不，不，那里只有山脉、冰川和几个随处可见的火山，而且在萨加斯里，有大量的巨魔和其他奇怪的生物。所以我们真正讨论的是沿海边缘地带。
That's where the fertile land is. And so, as you say, there's only so much of it. But that's where they go. That's where they end up. And is that the point at which, once it's full, that they move on? Because obviously there's a point at which they move on, right, to Greenland and then to, well, arguably. I mean, there's a huge debate about this north america yeah so land keeps on being parceled up and there's better land and there's
那里的土地才肥沃。所以，正如你所说，土地只有那么多。但这就是他们去的地方。那是他们最终落脚的地方。当它满员之后，是不是就在那个时候他们继续前进了？因为显然有一个他们继续前进的时刻，对吧？去格陵兰岛，然后去——可以说是北美。我是说，关于这个有一个巨大的争论。北美，是的。所以土地不断被瓜分，有较好的土地，也有
worse land and and so if you're there first and you're you're powerful you get a really good amount of land there's there's a text called land well there's various versions of a technical land armor book which means the book of settlement, which describes those first settlers and where they go and where they settle. But really, they're talking about the top dogs a lot of the time. And so we don't know how many other people have got small parcels of land. And it's not a case that you get there, you can't find any land. And so, well, on we go, let's try to find somewhere else. But the settlement of Iceland is part of this general movement, this kind of diasporic movement across the North Atlantic. The settlement of Greenland is something that happens quite a lot later and under different circumstances. And there is, again, farmable land. But really, by the time we get to Greenland, we're at the very edge of the sort of physical environment you can use to have a sustainable European style farming economy, which creates a lot of problems going forward.
较差的土地。如果你是第一批到达的而且很有权势，你就能分到非常好的土地。有一部文本叫做《土地占有书》（Landnámabók），也就是《定居之书》的不同版本，它描述了那些最早的定居者以及他们去哪里、在哪里定居。但实际上，他们很多时候谈论的都是顶层大人物。所以我们不知道还有多少其他人拥有小块土地。这并不是说你到了那里，找不到任何土地，然后就“好吧，我们继续前行，试着找别的地方吧”。但冰岛的定居是横跨北大西洋的这种普遍运动、这种散居运动的一部分。格陵兰岛的定居发生得要晚得多，而且是在不同的情况下。那里同样有可耕种的土地。但事实上，当我们到达格陵兰岛时，我们已经处于可持续的欧洲式农业经济所能利用的物理环境的极边缘，这在未来引发了许多问题。
And is it true that the name Greenland is coined as a kind of marketing scam to try to force people to go there. Yeah, well, that's what it says in the sagas. So Greenland isn't settled by the Norse, at least until the traditional date is around 985. So we're talking over 100 years since the start of the settlement of Iceland. And it's said to have been initially settled by this rather murderous outlaw who is outlawed from Norway for killings, goes to Iceland, is then outlawed from Iceland for killings and then goes off west and spends the three years of his outlawry going up and down the fjords of western Iceland, the coastline, trying to find somewhere to live, habitable land to settle and colonize then which and this is around 985 then we're told he goes back to iceland picks up his followers and his family and goes back then to settle greenland properly um and it's according to the two sagas that describe
“格陵兰”这个名字是为了强迫人们去那里而创造的一种营销骗局，这是真的吗？是的，萨加斯里就是这么说的。所以格陵兰岛并不是由诺斯人定居的，至少直到大约985年的传统日期之前是这样。所以我们谈论的是距离冰岛定居开始已经过去100多年了。据说它最初是由这个相当凶残的逃犯定居的，他因谋杀罪被从挪威驱逐出境，去了冰岛，然后又因谋杀罪被从冰岛驱逐出境，接着向西走，用他被流放的三年来来回回穿梭于冰岛西部的峡湾和海岸线，试图找到一个可以居住、定居和殖民的适宜居住的土地。然后——大约在985年——据说他回到了冰岛，带上他的追随者和家人，然后回到了格陵兰岛正式定居。而且，根据描述
that settlement of green and most strongly they're called the Vinland Sagas, the saga of Eric the Red and the saga of the Greenlanders. It is said that Eric calls Greenland, Greenland, because then it would be a more favourable place to settle. But to be fair- He's an estate agent. He's an estate. But I mean, I've spent time out
格陵兰定居的这两部最强有力的萨加——它们被称为《文兰萨加》（Vinland Sagas），即《红发埃里克萨加》（The Saga of Eric the Red）和《格陵兰人萨加》（The Saga of the Greenlanders）——据说埃里克把格陵兰岛命名为格陵兰（意为“绿色的土地”），是因为这样它会成为一个更适宜定居的地方。不过说实话——他是个房地产经纪人。他是个房地——但我的意思是，我曾在格陵兰岛做过田野调查。在夏天，它确实……所以在格陵兰岛有两个诺斯人的定居点，他们称之为东部定居点，规模要大得多。令人困惑的是，这两处都位于西海岸。然后是西部定居点，大约是前者的三分之一大小。它大约位于现代的努克（Nuuk）附近，那是格陵兰的首府，沿海岸再往上约300英里。当然，规模更大的东部定居点持续时间要长得多，它有自己的主教辖区，在夏天非常美丽、葱郁茂盛，在许多方面更适宜居住。问题部分出在后面，但冬天的白昼也更长、更加严酷。所以这才是
in Greenland doing research. And in the summer, it is, well, certainly. So there are two settlements in Greenland that the Norse, what they call the Eastern Settlement, which is a lot bigger. These are both on the West Coast, confusingly. And then there's the Western Settlement, which is about a third of the size. It's around modern day Nuuk, which is the capital of Greenland, about 300 miles further up the coast. And certainly the bigger Eastern Settlement, which lasts a lot longer, it has its own bishopric, it's really beautiful and green and lush in the summer, in many ways more habitable. The problems partly come later, but also the winters are longer and much, much harsher. So that's really
格陵兰岛真正的问题所在，但它并不全都是冰。只是关于航海之类的一个问题。所以，我的意思是，我无法想象如果你站在冰岛西海岸，是什么驱使你觉得：我要登上一艘船，然后一直往前开，看看有什么……是什么驱使他们认为那里甚至会有任何东西？因为这不像哥伦布认为“我会到达印度”。你知道，我知道我能到那里。你知道的，他们对任何事物都没有概念。
the issue with Greenland, but it's not all ice. Just a question about the voyages and stuff. So, I mean, I can't imagine what would possess you if you're standing on the west coast of Iceland to think, I'm going to get on a ship and just keep going and see what's... What possesses them to think that there's even anything there? Because it's not like Columbus thinking, I'll get to India. You know, I know I can get there. You know, they have no sense of anything.
还是说他们有？或者有一种隐约的感觉？他们是否认为那里有——你知道的，米德加尔德之蛇（Midgard serpent）之类的东西在深渊中翻腾，巨魔在海面上游荡？是的，我怀疑——
Or do they? Or is there some vague sense? And do they think that there are kind get there you know they have no sense of anything or do they or is there some vague sense and do they think that there are kind of you know the Midgard serpents and things toiling out there in the depths and giants roaming the seas and it's yeah I I suspect um I suspect there is a sense of yeah here be monsters at the edge of the world but I don't think that's the case when it comes to Greenland because well for, what you often find is the initial discovery and kind of semi-settlement of these places is accidental. People get blown off course. They might be trying to reach a parent somewhere further up the coast of Iceland, and then they just get blown out to sea. And then they are lucky enough to be the ones that then find land. I'm sure there are plenty of others
我怀疑有一种“此处有怪物”的感觉，就在世界的边缘。但我认为在格陵兰岛的情况并非如此，因为——原因在于，你经常会发现这些地方最初的发现和半定居是偶然的。人们被风吹离了航线。他们可能试图到达冰岛海岸更远处的某个地方，然后就被风吹到了大洋上。接着他们足够幸运，成为了发现土地的人。我确信还有很多其他人
that didn't, and therefore didn't discover Greenland. So that's the case in Greenland. But it's also you have to think that, you know, the Norse are a seafaring culture, and they're going to be picking up on a lot of signs that we wouldn't necessarily be picking up on so migratory birds for example so if you're seeing the birds heading out west well there's probably something out there you know you see it it's not that sense of we're at the edge of the world exactly yeah exactly yeah yeah there's there's plenty going on and driftwood even and so they settle greenland and then the same thing happens that people get blown off course and they end up basically in north America. I mean, and that's definite, isn't it? Because they found the settlement and all kinds of stuff. Yeah. Well, settlement is a grand word for what they find. And this in itself is significant. So, yeah. So Greenland, around, say, like I said, 985 or so, people start going out there what they call vinland like the like wine or you know berry land that is around the year 1000 which makes it nice and easy to remember and what that seems to be is a series of expeditionary parties possibly led by well certainly according to the
没有发现，因此也没有发现格陵兰岛。所以格陵兰岛的情况就是这样。但你也必须考虑到，诺斯人是一个航海民族，他们会捕捉到许多我们不一定能捕捉到的迹象——比如候鸟。如果你看到鸟儿向西飞去，好吧，那外面可能有什么东西，你知道的，你能看到它。这并非那种“我们正处于世界的边缘”的感觉，完全是的，完全是的，是的，那里有很多活动，甚至还有浮木。于是他们定居在格陵兰岛，然后同样的事情再次发生：人们被风吹离航线，最终基本上到达了北美。我的意思是，那是确凿无疑的，对吧？因为他们找到了定居点和各种各样的东西。是的。好吧，“定居点”对于他们所发现的东西来说是个宏大的词。而这本身就意义重大。所以，是的。所以格陵兰岛在——比如我说的，大约985年左右，人们开始去往那个他们称之为“文兰”（Vinland）的地方，就像葡萄酒的“文”或浆果土地，大约在公元1000年左右，这使得它很好记。而那似乎是一系列探险队，可能由——当然，根据
sagas led predominantly by er Eric the Red's children. So Leif the Lucky is the classic one that everyone knows about. And they go out there. And the first place, according to the sagas that they come, they call Hedluland, which seems to be sort of Baffin Island. It's very stony and rocky. That's what Hedluland means. It's like stone slab land they then come further down the coast to a much more green and wooded um place which they call mark land which means forest land and then they keep
萨加斯的记载，主要由红发埃里克的孩子们领导。所以“幸运者莱夫”（Leif the Lucky）是每个人都知道的经典人物。他们出海了。根据萨加斯的记载，他们到达的第一个地方叫做海卢兰（Helluland），似乎有点像巴芬岛（Baffin Island）。那里非常多石、多岩石。这就是海卢兰的意思。就像石板地一样。他们接着沿着海岸往下走，来到一个更加翠绿、森林密布的地方，
heading down and this is according to the sagas they keep heading down the coast and they then build huts and overwinter and men ships and um meet people do some some some nascent trading all goes a little bit wrong there's there's quite a lot of tension they go back but there's a series of these of these of these expeditions and it's really those the sagas those same the saga of the greenlanders and the saga of eric the red that describes these voyages to the edge of the North American continent. And so for many, many, many years, it was suspected that they had got there. But the sagas were really the main reason for that suspicion. But there was no archaeological evidence.
他们称之为马克兰（Markland），意思是森林之地。然后他们继续前行，根据萨加斯的记载，他们继续沿着海岸航行，然后建造小屋、过冬、配备船只、与人会面、进行一些最初的贸易。一切都有点出问题，存在相当多的紧张局势，他们回去了。但有一系列这样的探险活动，正是那些萨加斯——同样是《格陵兰人萨加》和《红发埃里克萨加》——描述了这些通往北美洲大陆边缘的航行。所以很多很多年里，人们一直怀疑他们曾到达那里。但萨加斯确实是这种怀疑的主要原因，不过当时并没有考古证据。
Then in the 60s, a husband and wife team called Helgi and Anna Ingstad actually were then directed to a place at the tip of Newfoundland, where locals said, look, I think there might be something there. And indeed, they found remnants of not permanent sites. So there are middens, there are rubbish heaps, but they're not very full. There's no evidence of burials we're looking more at something that may have lasted a decade or something it's used for overwintering for mending ships and then maybe as a springboard for going further south and seeing what they could find there um from that archaeological evidence and also from the sagas, it looks like the Vinland voyages are pretty short-lived.
然后在60年代，一对名为赫尔吉（Helgi）和安娜·英斯塔（Anna Ingstad）的夫妇被引导到了纽芬兰岛（Newfoundland）的最顶端，当地人说：“看，我觉得那里可能有什么东西。”果不其然，他们发现了遗迹，虽不是永久性遗址。所以那里有垃圾堆（middens），但并不是很满。没有埋葬的证据。我们看到的更可能是持续了十年左右的某种遗址，用于过冬、修补船只，然后可能是向南进一步探索、看看能在那里找到什么东西的跳板。从这些考古证据以及萨加斯来看，文兰航行似乎相当短暂。
We don't have permanent settlement. And according to the sagas, that's mostly because of the tensions they run into when they're dealing with the people who already live there. These are the skrylings, is that right? Yeah. So it's not a polite term so so so in the sagas skylings is the term for any um non-norse native inhabitants that they find in greenland so particularly the north of greenland where you've got inuit hunters and then over on the edge of the north american continent yeah and it's not polite it means like wretched scrawnywny little ones or something like that.
我们没有永久定居点。根据萨加斯的说法，这主要是因为他们在与已经住在那里的人打交道时遇到了紧张局势。这些就是“斯克林格”（Skraelings），对吗？是的。所以这不是一个礼貌的词——所以在萨加斯中，“斯克林格”是用来指他们在格陵兰岛发现的任何非诺斯原住民的术语——特别是格陵兰岛北部有因纽特人猎人的地方，然后是在北美洲大陆的边缘。这并不礼貌。它的意思是像可怜的、骨瘦如柴的小家伙之类的。
Yeah, well, of course. I mean, they would, wouldn't they? Yeah. It's like humans are humans. And Finland is thought to be New England. Is that the kind of likeliest? It's sort of slightly up. We're talking sort of tip of Newfoundland heading down to the St. Lawrence River area. We think archaeologically, we think they got as far as the St. Lawrence River because they find a type of nuts, butternuts in the archaeological layers up at the site that's called Lansome Meadows at the tip of Newfoundland. And those really only seem to grow as far north as it were as the St. Lawrence River area so so it looks like they got that far but we don't know how much further they got now you've mentioned a few times the sagas and we should probably get into the sagas because not so much of our evidence comes from the sagas I know
是的，当然。我的意思是，他们会这么叫的，对吧？人类就是人类。人们认为文兰是新英格兰吗？这是最有可能的吗？它稍微往上一点。我们讨论的是从纽芬兰岛的顶端一直延伸到圣劳伦斯河（St. Lawrence River）地区。在考古学上，我们认为他们到达了圣劳伦斯河，因为他们在纽芬兰岛顶端名为“兰斯奥牧草地”（L'Anse aux Meadows）的遗址的考古层中发现了某种坚果——胡桃（butternuts）。而这些坚果似乎只在最北到圣劳伦斯河一带生长，所以看起来他们确实走得那么远，但我们不知道他们走得有多远。现在，你已经多次提到萨加斯了，我们可能应该深入探讨一下萨加斯，因为我们的证据很大一部分来自萨加斯。我知道
we've got a break coming up but before the break what are the sagas they're not contemporary are they that's the thing no well they're not in the form we have them written down so you should probably start with the word saga it comes so we use it, yeah, if you're stuck in a horrible traffic jam or a family feud, oh, I've got a saga to tell you. gives us a clue as to the oral storytelling origins of the sagas. So the sagas are stories that are told in Iceland and over the years, from the earlier settlement period at least, you know, and over the years they're transmitted, they change, they're shaped by the mouths that tell them, you get new elements added, you get other elements taken out. Eventually, when we come to the 12th and very much 13th century, they start to be written down in Iceland. And those written forms of the sagas are what survive today, what we have. And they talk about all sorts of things. So the most famous
我们马上要休息一下，但在休息前，什么是萨加斯？它们不是当代作品，对吧？就是这样。嗯，它们在我们所拥有的书面形式中并不是——所以你可能应该从“萨加”（saga）这个词开始。它的来源是……我们使用它，是的，如果你陷入可怕的交通拥堵或家庭不和时，“哦，我有一个长篇大论（saga）要告诉你。”这为我们提供了一个线索，指向萨加 口头讲故事的起源。所以萨加是在冰岛讲述的故事，多年来，至少从早期的定居时期开始，多年来它们被传承、被改变、被讲述它们的口头所塑造，你会有新元素加入，其他元素被剔除。最终，当我们来到12世纪乃至13世纪时，它们开始在冰岛被记录下来。而这些萨加的书面形式就是今天幸存下来的、我们所拥有的东西。它们讲述了各种各样的事情。所以最著名的
ones are the sagas of Iceland, as you mentioned, Eil Saga at the top. I didn't pronounce it properly though. Oh, pretty close. I mean, honestly, I always worry very much about my pronunciation of everything, so I think we can put that to bed. We just enjoy the words and the names and the rest of it. That's good. You can definitely come again. But Eil Saga
那些是冰岛人萨加，正如你所提到的，顶部的《埃吉尔萨加》（Eil Saga）。不过我刚才发音不准。哦，相当接近了。说实话，我总是非常担心我对所有东西的发音，所以我想我们可以搁置这个了。我们只需欣赏这些单词、名字以及其他内容。那很好。你绝对可以再来。但是《埃吉尔萨加》
is one of the sagas of Icelanders. Eil is one of the first settlers of Iceland. You talked about, well you the the the extract you had is ulfer who's his father um he's he's meant to be a shapeshifter ulf literally means wolf um and he's one he they they that that's their their movement out to iceland and that's very typical of the sagas of iceland as you see their, what do you call it, their migration to Iceland, their settlement, and then it goes through stories of the settlers through the first decades or
是冰岛人萨加之一。埃吉尔是冰岛最早的定居者之一。你谈到——或者你拥有的节选是乌尔夫，他是他的父亲——他被认为是一个变形人，乌尔夫字面意思是“狼”——他是他们的……那是他们移居冰岛的故事，这非常典型地体现了冰岛人萨加，你看到了他们，你称之为他们的移民到冰岛、他们的定居，然后它通过前几十年或几个世纪里定居者的故事展开。有时这些萨加是关于个人的。例如，你会看到这些精彩的流放者萨加，吉斯拉萨加（Saga of Gísli）、格雷蒂尔萨加（Saga of Gretir），这些悲剧性的、破坏性的、具有社会破坏性的流放者人物。但随后你还会看到其他萨加，它们是关于跨越100多年的整个山谷或跨越几代人的家族的。但之后你还有其他种类的萨加。你有国王萨加，主要关于挪威国王，有时是丹麦国王。你有骑士萨加，基本上是中世纪冰岛和更广泛的斯堪的纳维亚对传奇故事的对应物，例如亚瑟王传奇人物，你有
centuries. Sometimes these sagas are about individuals. You get these amazing outlaw sagas, for example, the saga of Gísli, the saga of Gretir, these tragic, disruptive, socially disruptive outlaw figures. But then you get other sagas that are about whole valleys over 100 years or families spreading over several generations. But then you have other sorts of sagas as well. You have king's sagas that are about predominantly the kings of Norway, sometimes Denmark. You have chivalric sagas, which are basically the medieval Icelandic and broader more broadly Scandinavian equivalent of romances you know so Arthurian characters for example you have
关于古代英雄的传奇萨加……所以你有所有这些不同的故事，它们全都是萨加。而且，埃莉诺，我们还有被称为“散文埃达”（Prose Edda）和“诗体埃达”（Poetic Edda）的东西。是的。所以它们也属于这个范畴，它们讲述了神的故事。所以它们基本上是我们现在所理解的诺斯神话的源头。是的。对。所以它们不是萨加，但它们非常属于古诺斯文学的那一部分。而且它们来自冰岛。
you have um uh legendary sagas about about heroes of old um so you have all these different stories they're all sagas and Eleanor also um we have things called the prose and the poetic eddas. Yeah. So they would also come under the rubric and they tell the stories of the gods. So they're basically the source for Norse mythology as we now understand it. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So they're not sagas, but they're very much part of that body of Old Norse literature. And it's coming from Iceland.
正是如此。并且是在非常相似的文化背景下被写下来的。举个例子，大多数萨加都是匿名的，在这个意义上，我们当然不知道是谁写下或流传了它们。不过有一些国王萨加，我们很有可能知道它们是由13世纪的一个酋长、政治家、诗人斯诺里·斯蒂德鲁松（Snorri Sturluson）所写的。我们稍后可能会更多地谈论他。斯诺里也是写下《散文埃达》的人。而《散文埃达》是一本写于13世纪的诗人的手册。汤姆，这会直接切入你最喜欢的主题。他们必须将其记录下来的部分原因是因为传统的北欧诗人需要对古老的宗教（你知道的，神明）有非常深入的了解……有什么东西介入了吗？可能会有什么东西，我不知道那会是什么，会是基督教吗，汤姆？我想会的。我想
Very much. And written in a very similar cultural context. So to give you an example, most sagas are anonymous in the sense we don't know who wrote them down or transmitted them, of course. There are some King's sagas where we do know in all likelihood they're written by a 13th century chieftain, politician, poet called Snorri Sturtlusen. We might talk more about him later. Snorri is also the person who wrote down the Prose Edda. And the Prose Edda is a, it's written in the 13th century, it's a handbook for poets. And Tom, this will come straight onto your favourite subject. Part of the reason that they have to be written down is because traditional nordic poets need to know an awful lot about um the old religion you know the gods and has something intervened something that might i don't know what would that be could it be christianity tom i think it could i think
会的。我认为这绝对是休息的绝佳时机。所以我们要做的就是休息一下。你可以在休息期间和埃莉诺谈谈基督教，同时为挪威《Vogue》拍照。然后我们回来，在休息后谈论一些更有趣的事情。所以休息过后，我会回来，朗读我从板球巡回赛中写下的斯卡尔德诗，然后我们来谈谈冰岛的基督教化以及这给解读萨加带来的复杂性。
it could i think this is i think this is the perfect spot at which which to take a break so what we'll do is we'll take a break. You can talk to Eleanor about Christianity in the break while being photographed for Norwegian Vogue. And then we can come back and talk about something more interesting after the break. So after the break, I'll come back, read my Scaldic verse from our cricket tour, and then we'll talk about the Christianisation of Iceland and the complications that this sets up for interpreting the sagas.
非常好。一会见。一会见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的
Very good. See you in a minute. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our
问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的机会，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com。冰岛暴风雪的深层足迹，挥舞球棒的强者，击败敌球的杀手，深受奥丁青睐，他们与海雀搏斗。那是在冰岛写的一首诗，由我所作，为了庆祝大约四年前我们以1-2输给冰岛板球队。
Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to ther to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com the deep tracks of iceland's blizzards fell wielders of the bat foe and ball slayer favoured by Odin, they fought the puffin. That was a poem written in Iceland, written by me to celebrate our 2-1 defeat by the Icelandic cricket team about four years ago.
我能在Zoom通话上看到多米尼克开心的脸。他马上要变得更开心了，因为我们和埃莉诺在一起。我们要聊聊公元1000年，当时按照传统，冰岛人民决定皈依基督教。埃莉诺，你知道的，我正面对着多米尼克的怀疑。请向我保证这是一个重要的时刻。这不仅重要，多米尼克，我要试着把它
And I can see Dominic's happy face on the Zoom call at that. And he's about to get even happier because we're with Eleanor. And we're going to talk about the year 1000 when, by tradition, the people of Iceland decided to become Christian. And Eleanor, just, you know, I'm facing the scepticism of Dominic here. Please reassure me this is a significant moment. It's not only significant. Dominic, I'm going to try and a significant moment it's it's not only significant Dominic I'm going to try and make it sexy and bloodthirsty right okay Tom never does he Tom is neither of those things well let's let's give it a go so so we've got the whole of Europe
讲得性感而嗜血，对吧，汤姆？汤姆从来不这样，汤姆这两样都不是。好吧，让我们试一试。所以，整个欧洲要么已经基督教化，要么正在基督教化。挪威加入这个行列稍微晚了一点，但在公元995年即位了一位雄心勃勃的基督教化国王，对吧？他叫奥拉夫·特里格瓦松（Olaf Tryggvason）。我们需要了解他才能理解。在公元1000年之前的二十家里，我们开始看到一些传教士进入冰岛。所以这些通常是冰岛传教士。他们离开，去往欧洲大陆，然后带着基督教试图将其带回冰岛。这就是它变得有点性感的地方。不要抱太大希望，
either Christianized or Christianizing Norway comes a little bit late to the party, but it has a big Christianizing king who comes to the throne in 995 AD, right? He's called Olaf Trudforsen. We need to know about him to understand. Over the two decades leading up to around 1000 AD, we start to see some missionaries coming into Iceland. So these are generally Icelandic missionaries. They leave, they go to the continent, and then they come back trying to bring Christianity with them. This is where it gets a little bit sexy. Don't hold your hopes up too much.
因为这些真的是相当令人讨厌的人。我们说的是维京传教士。这些人到处走动，试图通过武力强迫人们改宗、砸碎偶像。有一个极好的……所以其中一位第一批传教士变得非常非常生气。他和一个主教来到冰岛，没有人想成为基督徒，每个人都开始嘲笑他，并创作讽刺诗来质疑这位传教士和这位主教之间纯洁关系的性质。我想有一个地方，它是怎么说的？
But because these are really quite unpleasant people. We're talking Viking missionaries. These are people who go around the country trying to convert people by force, smashing up idols. There is a brilliant um that so one of the first missionaries gets really really cross he comes to iceland with a bishop and no one wants to be christian and everyone starts taking the piss out of him and composing scurrilous verses questioning the pure nature of the relationship between said missionary and said bishop. I think there's a point where, what's it, what's it,
你是所有主教宝宝的妈妈。就是那种东西。他们变得如此——如果你是这个时期的维京人，这是一件非常侮辱人的事情。于是他去杀了一些人，被宣布为不受法律保护的人。然后下一个砸碎了所有的异教偶像，被宣布不受法律保护。然后下一个遭到嘲笑，于是杀了人，被宣布不受法律保护。然后下一个砸碎了所有的异教偶像，被宣布不受法律保护。然后下一个遭到嘲笑，于是杀了人，被宣布不受法律保护。所以这不是——
you're the mummy of all the bishop's babies. It's that sort of stuff. And they get so, this is a really insulting thing to say if you are a Viking at this time. So he then goes and kills some people and gets outlawed. And then the next one smashes up all the pagan idols and gets outlawed. And then the next one has the piss taken out of him and so kills people and gets outlawed. And then the next one smashes up all the pagan idols and gets outlawed. And then the next one has the piss taken out of him and so kills people and gets outlawed. So it's not-
你是主教所有孩子的妈。就是这种恶心人的话。对当时的维京人来说，这是极具侮辱性的言论。于是他去杀了几个人，被判为不受法律保护的人。接着下一个砸碎了所有的异教偶像，也被判为不受法律保护。然后下一个被人取笑，于是杀了几个人，又被判为不受法律保护。接着下一个砸碎了所有的异教偶像，也被判为不受法律保护。然后下一个被人取笑，于是杀了几个人，又被判为不受法律保护。所以这不是——
It's muscular Christianity. It's very muscular, quite fragile Christianity. Yeah, they're not good at having a joke at their expense. So it gets up to the year 1000. And basically the Christians in Iceland and the pagans in iceland and the pagans in iceland are all pretty pissed off at each other and they want different law courts they want different procedures they just they don't want anything to do with each other
这就是肌肉基督教。这是非常肌肉发达、又相当脆弱的基督教。是的，他们很不擅长拿自己开玩笑。时间来到了公元1000年。基本上，冰岛的基督徒和冰岛的异教徒、冰岛的异教徒彼此都非常恼火，他们想要不同的法庭，想要不同的程序，他们就是不想和对方有任何瓜葛
meanwhile this norwegian christianizing king is lurking in the wings basically saying you need to start christianizing or i'm going to come and do it for you and so the iceland is like right okay fine fine so at the big parliament, it's called the Althing, so everyone meets together, and one of the chieftains is tasked with deciding whether the country is going to turn Christian or not. And so he goes and hides under a skin in his tent for a day and a night or something.
与此同时，这位挪威的基督教化国王正潜伏在暗处，基本上是在说：你们得开始信奉基督教了，否则我就要亲自来帮你们了。于是冰岛人觉得：好吧，好吧，那就这样吧。所以在议会上，也就是所谓的“阿尔辛格”（Althing），大家聚在一起，其中一位酋长被委任来决定这个国家是要皈依基督教还是不皈依。于是他去帐篷里用兽皮把自己盖起来，躲了一天一夜或者类似的时间。
That's how they do it in Christianity in Iceland. And I think, I'm pretty sure he's pagan himself, but he decides the most pragmatic thing is that, no, they do Christianize. Except he says, well, look, the pagans can carry on eating horse flesh. You can still sacrifice babies. You can still worship idols. Just do it privately, you know. That's not how Christianity works, right? In the Nordic world, works right in the world it's very very general
这就是他们在冰岛信基督教的方式。而且我想，我很确定他自己是个异教徒，但他认为最务实的做法是，不，他们还是得皈依基督教。不过他说，嗯，看吧，异教徒可以继续吃马肉。你们还是可以献祭婴儿。你们还是可以崇拜偶像。只要私下里做就行了，你知道的。基督教可不是这么运作的，对吧？在北欧世界，在世界上的运作方式非常非常普遍
simmer and and in fact my my favorite detail is that when they're all then told well you're going to have to be baptized because it's iceland there's a lot of nice cozy um hot springs and so everyone at the parliament basically says well we're not getting not getting baptised here because the water's cold. So we'll wait till we're on the way back. When we get to our local hot springs, then we'll get baptised. Thank you very much. So that's the context for the official baptism of the official conversion of Iceland. But it takes a long time and there are still plenty of people who are uh you know believing in the old gods or believing in the old gods in particular circumstances so if you go to sea you might pray to thor if you're on land you might pray to christ it just depends on so when i went to iceland there was there
酝酿着，事实上我最喜欢的细节是，当他们所有人都被告知“嗯，你们必须接受洗礼，因为这里是冰岛，有很多舒适的、温暖的温泉”时，议会上的每个人基本上都说：“嗯，我们可不在冰岛接受洗礼，因为这水太冷了。所以我们要等到回程的路上。等我们到了当地的温泉，我们再接受洗礼。非常感谢。”所以，这就是冰岛官方洗礼、官方皈依的背景。但这需要很长时间，而且仍然有很多人呃，你知道的，信仰着旧神，或者在特定情况下信仰旧神。所以如果你出海，你可能会向托尔祈祷；如果你在陆地上，你可能会向基督祈祷，这完全取决于……所以当我去了冰岛，那里有
were all these stories about you'd be driving along a straight road and then there'd be a bend and the big and and and the the ic would say, well, this is because the elves were there. And therefore we had to... And is that just a story that they tell gullible tourists or is there actually a belief still to this day that elves and such spirits are manifest in the landscape? So obviously I'm not Icelandic. I can't talk for people's inner beliefs. But certainly, well, I mean, there are quite a lot of, let's tour the elf houses of southern Reykjavik for a fair price sort of tours going on. But no, you're right that yes, they do have a sense that there are other things in the landscape that aren't human. And that's okay, but just be respectful. So I think, yeah, there are certainly people who do believe things like that still. And yeah, I mean, you've both been to Iceland. The landscape itself is uncanny. A lot of the, you know, there are things that look like trolls, just petrified. Yeah, and you've got smoke coming out of the ground and all that sort of
各种各样的故事，说你正开着车走在一条直路上，然后前面有个弯道，然后那个大……冰岛人会说：“哦，这是因为那里有精灵。因此我们不得不……”这只是他们用来对付容易受骗的游客的故事，还是至今仍然有人相信精灵之类的灵魂在风景中显现？所以，显然我不是冰岛人。我无法代表人们内心的信仰。但当然，我的意思是，有相当多的、诸如“以合理的价格游览雷克雅未克南部的精灵屋”之类的旅游团正在进行。但你说得对，是的，他们确实有一种感觉，即风景中存在着并非人类的其他事物。这没关系，但只要保持尊重就行。所以我认为，是的，确实还有人仍然相信诸如此类的事情。而且，是的，我的意思是，你们俩都去过冰岛。风景本身就不可思议。许多……你知道的，有些东西看起来就像巨魔，只是变成了化石。是的，你还会看到地面上冒烟诸如此类的
stuff. Why wouldn't you believe in trolls and elves and dragons? Exactly, yeah. So then going back to what we were saying before the break, you know, when we have these 13th century texts, we have the Prose Edda written by Snorri Sturluson. It's this mythological handbook to help poets because these poets are now Christian. The worry is that they've forgotten all the old stories that mean that they can write poetry
东西。你为什么不相信巨魔、精灵和龙呢？完全正确，是的。那么回到我们在中场休息前讨论的话题，你知道的，当我们拥有这些13世纪的文本时，我们有了由斯诺里·斯图鲁松（Snorri Sturluson）撰写的《散文埃达》（Prose Edda）。这是一本神话手册，用来帮助诗人们，因为这些诗人们现在已经是基督徒了。令人担心的是，他们已经忘记了所有的旧故事，而这些故事能让他们写出
just as beautifully as Tom tom did you know but because a lot of this that's the right thing to say but a lot of this poetry does draw on the old myths and the god odin the one-eyed god is meant to be the god of poetry so you really need those cultural um points in order to in order to participate in this very important sort of um cultural practice the the the other big text for the mythology is again 13th century um from a manuscript from about 1270 called the the codex regis the the king's codex um and that is the poetic edda and that's all the that's a collection, it's an enormous collection of all the poems
和汤姆一样优美的诗歌，你知道的，但因为这其中的许多——这才是正确的话——但其中许多诗歌确实借鉴了古老的神话，独眼神奥丁被认为是诗歌之神，所以你真的需要这些文化要点，以便能够参与这种非常重要的文化实践。关于神话的另一部重要文献同样来自13世纪，来自一份大约1270年的手稿，被称为《王权抄本》（Codex Regius），即国王的手稿，那部作品就是《诗体埃达》（Poetic Edda），那是所有诗歌的集合
of the gods and the heroes of old, the sort of heroes that end up in Wagner's Ring Cycle, but also the gods that end up in Marvel films, Loki, Thor, Odin, Frey, all the rest of it. And so what is the scholarly thinking on how authentic the transmission of the poetic edda is so are these unmediated by christian influences can we kind of say this is what you know what the ancient vikings it's a genuine question um Or, you know, are things like Ragnarok, the end of the world, and the stories of Odin and Thor and everything, have they been kind of, well, slightly transmuted by Christian assumptions and influence? unmediated trust nothing basically everything's dodgy particularly when it's gone through hundreds potentially potentially hundreds of years of or when i say it's gone through hundreds
关于古代的神灵和英雄，那些最终出现在瓦格纳《尼伯龙根的指环》中的英雄，还有那些最终出现在漫威电影中的神灵，洛基、托尔、奥丁、弗雷以及所有其他神灵。那么，学术界对于《诗体埃达》的传承有多纯正有什么看法呢？这些是未经基督教影响中介的吗？我们是否可以断言，这就是你知道的古代维京人……这是一个真正的问题，或者，你知道的，诸如诸神黄昏、世界末日以及奥丁和托尔等人的故事，它们是否在某种程度上被基督教的假设和影响所改变或渗透了？未经中介，什么都不要相信，基本上所有东西都不可靠，特别是当它经历了数百个、潜在的数百年的时间，或者当我说它经历了数百
of years of being orally transmitted that doesn't make it intrinsically unreliable not at all it's just that anything that is that old from source to text we can't tell exactly what's happened to it also we only have really we have a couple of poems knocking around elsewhere but but really if this manuscript hadn't survived we wouldn't have yeah the vast vast majority it really and then you have to think how many other things didn't survive you know we know there were shipwrecks in in the early modern period carrying potentially dozens of these manuscripts who knows what was was there? That's terrible. How many Marvel superheroes are we missing out on? It's tragic.
年口耳相传，这并不意味着它本身就不可靠，一点也不。只是任何如此古老的东西，从源头到文本，我们都无法确切说出它经历了什么。此外，我们实际上只有一些在其他地方流传的诗歌，但说实话，如果这份手稿没有保存下来，我们就不会拥有绝大多数的内容了。真的，然后你得想想，还有多少其他东西没有存活下来？你知道的，我们知道在近代早期曾有沉船载着可能几十份这样的手稿，谁知道里面有什么呢？太可怕了。我们错失了多少漫威超级英雄？这太悲剧了。
So we don't really know what we don't know is the point. And we don't know how... I mean, so some of these poems look like they could be taking the piss out of the gods. Others look like they could have much older authentic roots. And certainly some of the things that are described in the poems, we then see in other sorts of sources. So runic inscriptions, picture stones, things that make us realise, okay, there's some truth behind these stories. We just have to piece all the little bits together. And Eleanor, so, I mean, by the 13th century, the saga writers are devoutly
所以我们并不真正知道我们所不知道的是什么。而且我们也不知道如何……我的意思是，这些诗歌中有些看起来像是在取笑神灵。另一些则看起来可能有着更古老、更纯正的根源。当然，诗歌中描述的一些事情，我们在其他类型的来源中也能看到。比如符文铭文、图画石，这些东西让我们意识到，好吧，这些故事背后确实有一些真相。我们只需要把所有这些零碎的片段拼凑起来就行了。那么埃莉诺，我的意思是，到了13世纪，萨迦的作家们都是虔诚的
Christian. I mean, it's not like they're kind of secretly Odin worshippers or anything. So, what is their attitude to this body of mythology? It's quite comfortingly nice for the most part of it. So, let's talk about the sagas, because yeah, there are conversion narratives in a lot of the sagas. And what that means is then there are a lot of pagan characters in the sagas, pre-conversion or in the process of being converted. But really, the sense you get there is that these are people's ancestors. This is people's cultural and personal heritage. So you're not going to be disrespectful of them. So there will be comments such as,
基督徒。我的意思是，这并不是说他们是什么秘密的奥丁崇拜者之类的人。那么，他们对这整套神话的态度是什么？对于绝大多数内容来说，这其实让人感到相当宽慰和舒适。所以，让我们来谈谈萨迦，因为是的，许多萨迦中都有关于皈依的故事。这意味着萨迦中有很多异教徒角色，要么在皈依前，要么正处于皈依的过程中。但真的，你从那里获得的感觉是，这些人是大家的祖先。这是人们的文化和个人遗产。所以你不会对他们不敬。因此会有这样的评论，比如
you know, he lived in a time before the conversion or, you know, he believed in these gods or, but he acted in a way that was, you know, good and noble. It's not this sort of demonization that you get.
你知道的，他生活在皈依之前的时代，或者，你知道的，他信仰这些神灵，但他行事的方式是，你知道的，善良而高尚的。这并不是那种你所熟知的妖魔化。
But what about the gods themselves? Oh, the gods themselves. Because the gods themselves, I mean, Odin is an incredibly powerful kind of menacing, hypnotic figure in a lot of these. Yeah. So in the sagas, the gods do sometimes crop up, particularly in the more outlandish sagas.
但神灵本身呢？哦，神灵本身。因为神灵本身——我的意思是，在许多这样的故事中，奥丁是一种极其强大、具有威胁性、催眠力的形象。是的。所以在萨迦中，神灵有时确实会突然出现，特别是在那些更加离奇的萨迦中。
And there they often are quite unpleasant. You know, there's a ship um lost at sea on the way to greenland and suddenly thor will appear and say i'll wreck you on these rocks if you don't believe in me you know so they are a little bit demonic um but then they don't crop up very often in the sagas in the eddas in the prose edda by snorri and in the poetic edit of all those poems. No, it's more like what you would see in, I don't know, Greek or Roman pantheons of gods. They're more than human. They're bawdy.
在那里，他们通常相当令人不快。你知道的，有一艘船在去格陵兰岛的途中在海上失事了，突然托尔会现身说：“如果你不信仰我，我就让你们在这片礁石上船毁人亡”，你知道的，所以他们有点像恶魔；但随后他们在萨迦中出现得并不频繁，而在埃达中，在斯诺里的《散文埃达》以及所有这些诗歌的《诗体埃达》中。不，这更像是你在我不知道的希腊或罗马神话万神殿中看到的情形。他们超越了人类。他们粗俗。
They're badly behaved. They're dangerous. They're funny, you know, but they're not necessarily evil. The only sort of exception is that, of course, Snorri is writing within this Christian framework. And so it's sometimes hard to tell how many of his stories are being mediated through that lens I mean they have to be to some extent so for example he calls Loki something like that you know the the malevolent culminator of all the gods he's that he's the baddie he's the mischief maker
他们行为不端。他们很危险。他们很有趣，你知道的，但他们不一定是邪恶的。唯一的例外是，当然，斯诺里是在这个基督教框架内写作的。因此，有时很难分辨他的多少故事是通过那个视角进行中介的。我的意思是，在某种程度上它们必须是这样的。例如，他称洛基为类似这样的话，你知道的，诸神中所有邪恶的罪魁祸首，他就是那个坏蛋，那个恶作剧制造者。
and there's and he calls Odin the all-father. And so it's possible he's drawing on that sort of Christian framework with which to explain the gods to a Christian audience. And the notorious issue is around Ragnarok, isn't it? Which is the end of the world, the end of the gods, the wolf, Fenris, the wolf turning up and devouring everything. And there is debate, isn't there, about the degree to which this might be influenced by Book of Revelation and Christian anxieties about the end of the world? Exactly. And what's your thought on that? Well, I think that there are an awful lot of cultural influences that are going to be just in the air, just knocking around 13th century
还有，他称奥丁为众神之父。因此，他有可能是在借鉴那种基督教框架，以便向基督教受众解释这些神灵。而众所周知的问题围绕着诸神黄昏，不是吗？也就是世界末日，诸神的终结，巨狼芬里尔出现并吞噬一切。关于这在多大程度上可能受到《启示录》以及基督教对世界末日的焦虑的影响，一直存在争论，不是吗？确实如此。你对此有什么看法？嗯，我认为有大量的文化影响将会弥漫在空气中，充斥在13世纪的
Iceland. Some of these are going to be Christian, some of these are going to be learned European, some of these are going to be older sort of native tradition, there's going to be all sorts. So at the end of one of the poems, yeah, it's been suggested suddenly this dragon appears in the sky, but it is sort of Book of Revelation, the sort of dragon rather than traditional Nordic Fafnir-type dragon, possibly. On the other hand, there are other potential influences. So in the case of Ragnarok, in the poems that describe Ragnarok, it's fire and it's darkness covering the world and it's nuclear winters almost.
冰岛。其中一些将是基督教的，一些将是博学的欧洲传统的，一些将是更古老的本土传统，各种各样的都有。所以在其中一首诗的结尾，是的，有人提出天空中突然出现了这条巨龙，但它更像是《启示录》中的那种巨龙，而不是传统的北欧法夫纳（Fafnir）式的巨龙，这很有可能。另一方面，还有其他潜在的影响。所以在诸神黄昏的案例中，在描述诸神黄昏的诗歌中，那是烈火，是黑暗笼罩世界，几乎就像是核冬天。
And it has been suggested there that what they're drawing on is a long, long lived cultural memory of really terrible events or huge volcanoes that have gone off in the past. Yeah. Maybe going back to the 5th century,
并且有人提出，他们所借鉴的是一种长期存在的文化记忆，关于过去发生的真正可怕的事件或巨大的火山爆发。
6th century, even that sense that the world is unstable and may end in ways that we have very little control over. So who knows how much of that is also working its way into myths such as Ragnarok. Great. That's enough Christianity.
6世纪，甚至那种世界是不稳定的、可能会以我们几乎无法控制的方式走向终结的感觉。所以谁知道其中有多少成分也在潜移默化地融入诸神黄昏这样的神话中呢？太棒了。基督教的内容就到这里吧。
We haven't talked about sagas very broadly, but we haven't really zeroed in on any particular sagas. So do you have a favourite? Do you have a couple of favourites? Oh, I have so many favourites. Well, I mean, I suppose it depends what direction we want to go in. Should we go back to Greenland? Because there's some quite lovely... Sure. Well, Eleanor, I wondered if... Because my two favourite characters are both women.
我们还没有广泛地谈论过萨迦，而且也没有真正聚焦于任何特定的萨迦。那么你有一个最喜欢的吗？你有几个最喜欢的吗？哦，我有太多最喜欢的了。嗯，我的意思是，我想这取决于我们想往哪个方向走。我们应该回到格陵兰岛吗？因为那里有一些相当可爱的……当然。嗯，埃莉诺，我想知道，因为我最喜欢的两个角色都是女性。
Yes. And one of them is the evil sister of Leif Erikson, Freydis. Evil according to one saga and good according one. Good according to the other. Yes. So she's a complex figure. And then there's this remarkable woman, Gudrid, who supposedly gives birth. Could you just tell us about them?
是的。其中一个是莱夫·埃里克森（Leif Erikson）邪恶的妹妹弗雷迪斯（Freydis）。根据一个萨迦的说法她是邪恶的，而根据另一个萨迦……根据另一个萨迦她是善良的。是的。所以她是一个复杂的形象。然后还有这个非凡的女性古德里德（Gudrid），据说她生下了孩子。你能给我们讲讲他们吗？
Because they're both kind of wonderful figures. And it's a reminder that the female figures in the sagas are kind of just as amazing as the men. I totally agree. And that's sort of why I wanted to head back to Greenland
因为她们都是非常棒的人物。这也提醒我们，萨迦中的女性形象和男性形象一样惊艳。我完全同意。这也是为什么我想回到格陵兰岛的原因
because exactly like you say, these two wonderful characters, there are very strong female characters throughout the sagas. And in fact, often you'll find that the females are more psychologically complex than the males. The males are often quite, you know, Yeah, the vegan, yeah, off I go.
因为就像你说的，这两个精彩的角色，整个萨迦中都有非常强大的女性角色。事实上，你经常会发现女性在心理上比男性更复杂。男性通常相当……你知道的，是的，维京人，是的，我这就出发。
But, you know, the women women are what's the music they do again it's the music again you did us a little tune there i did like to have a musical you can see was me flexing my um my my muscles your muscles yeah if i if i had an axe i would hold up it was very intimidating i think you've been watching too many children's cartoons yeah that was definitely more nog in the nog wasn't it yeah anyway i threw you off tell us about the women so so for example i i lack style a saga the saga of the the people of salmon valley it has this very very strong woman at the heart of it um gudrun who ends up with four husbands another lover and outlives them all not entirely coincidentally and is
但是，你知道的，女性……她们又在放什么音乐了？又是音乐，你刚才给我们奏了一小段曲子。我确实喜欢来点音乐，你可以看出那是我在展示我的……我的肌肉。你的肌肉，是的。如果我有一把斧头，我会把它举起来。这太吓人了，我觉得你看的儿童动画片太多了。是的，那绝对更像《诺格》（Noggin the Nog）里的东西，对吧？是的，不管怎样，你打断了我的思绪。给我们讲讲女性吧——比如，我缺少《拉克斯代尔萨迦》（Laxdæla saga），也就是鲑鱼谷之民的萨迦，它的核心是一个非常非常强大的女性，古德伦（Gudrun），她最终经历了四段婚姻、另一个情人，并且活过了他们所有人，这绝非巧合，而且她
it's really really strong and powerful and quite formidable. But yes, in Vinland, in the two Vinland sagas, the saga of Eric the Red and the saga of the Greenlanders, we have these extraordinary characters. Do we know if they're historical? They may well have been, maybe not in the form that we have them good read that or good read is um she ends up on these voyages to uh the edge of the north american continent she at that point is married to a man called carl stephanie which means sort of the stuff that men are made of and she is a very very important figure earlier in Earlier in the sagas, she helps this... The Old Norse term is vulva, but it's sort of like a seeress.
真的非常强大、非常有威慑力。但是，是的，在文兰（Vinland），在两部文兰萨迦中，《红发埃里克萨迦》（Saga of Erik the Red）和《格陵兰人萨迦》（Saga of the Greenlanders），我们拥有这些非凡的角色。我们知道她们是历史人物吗？她们很可能是，也许并不像我们所拥有的那样……古德里德，古德里德是……她最终参与了这些通往北美洲大陆边缘的航行，当时她嫁给了一个名叫卡尔瑟芬尼（Karlsefni）的男子，这个名字的意思是“男子汉的材料”，她在萨迦的前半部分是一个非常非常重要的人物。在萨迦的早期，她帮助了一位……
I know, Dominic, yeah, again, you can't see. There was definitely a raised eyebrow going on there. It's the Old Norse term for a pagan seeress. And Greenland is going through a terrible famine. And so this seeress is called upon to perform these spells that Gudrid helps with in order to try and summon good spirits in order to bring about the famine. She then goes off to Vinland and exactly like you say, Tom,
我知道，多米尼克，是的，又来了，你看不见。当时绝对有一个挑眉的动作。那是古诺斯语中对异教女先知的称呼。当时格陵兰岛正经历着可怕的饥荒。于是这位女先知被请来施展法术，古德里德协助这些法术，试图召唤善良的精灵来消除饥荒。然后她去了文兰，正如你所说的那样，汤姆，
she's in the sagas said to be the first European person from over want to say, yeah, European sort of person from over the seas to the west to give birth. She gives birth to a little boy called Snorri. So he's the first European American. Yes, according to the sagas. Yeah, exactly.
萨迦中说她是第一个从西方海外来到这里的欧洲人，并在那里生下了孩子。她生下了一个名叫斯诺里的小男孩。所以他是第一个欧洲裔美国人。是的，根据萨迦的记载。是的，完全正确。
Freydis, who is one of the children of Eric the Red, and also takes part in, according to the sagas, these adventures Freydis, who is one of the children of Eric the Reds and also takes parts in, according to the sagas, these, um, these adventures to the West is even more interesting. Part of the reason she's so interesting is because in one of the sagas, she is most definitely a baddie. Uh, she's quite terrifying. She gets into a feud with another ship that they've gone out with, um, which is led by two brothers. She doesn't like where this is going. And so she persuades her husband and the other people in her party to murder the brothers. And there are, I think, five women in the brothers' party, and so
弗雷迪斯是红发埃里克的孩子之一，根据萨迦的记载，她也参与了这些通往西方的冒险。弗雷迪斯是红发埃里克的孩子之一，根据萨迦的记载，她也参与了这些冒险，嗯，通往西方的冒险，她甚至更有趣。她之所以如此有趣，部分原因在于在一个萨迦中，她绝对是个坏蛋。她相当吓人。她与他们一同出海的另一艘船发生了宿怨，那艘船由两兄弟带领。她不喜欢事情这样发展。于是她游说她的丈夫和她这一派的其他人去谋杀这两兄弟。当时兄弟那一派里好像有五个女人，所以
no one will murder them. And so she just says, put an axe in my hand, hand me an axe, and she finishes them off for herself. It's quite terrifying. And then it's said that she swears everyone to secrecy. When they get back to Greenland, things start to come out, what's happened. And it's meant to be a really, really dark and terrible event. But what's interesting is in the other saga, she's nothing like that. She is very formidable. And there's a point where relations between the Norse explorers and the locals, the tribe who live there, have broken down and people have been killed. And it's very unpleasant. At one point, all the Norse run away.
没有人愿意去谋杀她们。于是她直接说：“把斧头交到我手里，给我一把斧头，”然后她亲自解决了她们。这相当可怕。然后据说她让所有人都发誓保密。当他们回到格陵兰岛时，事情开始败露，发生了什么也被知道了。这本该是一个非常非常黑暗和可怕的事件。但有趣的是，在另一个萨迦中，她完全不是那样。她非常令人敬畏。有一次，北欧探险者与当地人、即住在当地的部族之间的关系彻底破裂，有人被杀。情况非常糟糕。有一次，所有的北欧人都逃跑了。
But Freydis is heavily pregnant, and so she can't run away and so the saga tells us that she picks up a sword from one of the the fallen people and she bears her breast and she slaps the sword against her breast and the the the natives who are um and they're so terrified that they run away and so that's how they might well this is it so so that's one of those strange things where you don't know whether that would have meant more to the original saga audience when they were listening or later reading, or that would be absolutely bizarre because when they get... Presumably this was in the summer.
但弗雷迪斯怀有身孕，所以她无法逃跑，于是萨迦告诉我们，她从一个倒下的死者手中捡起了一把剑，她袒露出胸膛，用剑拍打着自己的胸膛，那些当地人……他们吓得落荒而逃。所以这就是他们……好吧，这就是其中一件奇怪的事情，你不知道这对于最初听故事或后来阅读的萨迦受众来说是否更有意义，或者这绝对是匪夷所思的，因为当他们到达时……据推测这是在夏天。
Well, we hope so. Yes, that's not frostbite you'd welcome, is it? No, so what's interesting there is that these two the vinland sagas the greenlanders and um the um the saga of oak the reds they don't seem to have any when i say textual connection they don't seem to have been copied from each other they seem to be drawing from the same pool of oral traditions that have been brought down the centuries and so the fact that there are so many similarities between them says something about the strength of that oral
嗯，我们希望如此。是的，那可不是你想要的冻伤，对吧？不，所以有趣的是，这两部文兰萨迦——《格陵兰人萨迦》和《红发埃里克萨迦》——它们似乎没有任何……当我说是文本联系时，它们似乎并不是互相抄袭的，它们似乎汲取自代代相传的同一口口头传统池塘。因此，它们之间有如此多的相似之处，这说明了代代相传的这种口头
tradition that is being passed down but also the fact that then you end up with a character like Freydis who is presented so differently in each one is is fascinating isn't it it's like what's the truth behind that is there any at all and are these stories that are being you we've talked a bit about how they're told and retold and so on so are they told within family groups um as sort of bedtime stories or as sort of a shared heritage or are they told publicly at big sort of feasts and sort of you know council meetings and stuff like that how does that work it's probably a bit of both um certainly we know that medieval Icelandic society is operating on all sorts of levels on this, this oral, kind of different levels of public oral tradition and then private oral tradition.
传统的强大力量，但同时也意味着最终你会得到像弗雷迪斯这样在每个故事中呈现得如此不同的角色，这不是很迷人吗？这就像是：背后的真相是什么？到底有没有真相？这些是你一直在讲述的故事，我们之前讨论过它们是如何被讲述和重新讲述的等等，所以它们是在家族内部被当作睡前故事或某种共同的遗产来讲述的，还是在盛大的宴会和各种议会会议等场合公开讲述的？这到底是怎么运作的？可能两者兼而有之吧，嗯……当然，我们知道中世纪冰岛社会在各个层面上都在运作这种口头传统，这种口头传统分为不同的层面：公开的口头传统和私下的口头传统。
So we mentioned Snorri in the 13th century. Snorri is at one point the chief law speaker at the National Parliament. But these law speakers up to the early 12th century, their main duty is over the course of three years, every yearly parliament, they recite a third of the laws. So then all the laws have been recited. So we have oral tradition operating on that scale and so when we're talking about the saga stories the genealogies there's no reason why that wouldn't be the case but at the same time we then have we have family groups what we tend to have is is farms that don't just have one family but they have an extended family or they have you know people working there people
所以我们提到了13世纪的斯诺里。斯诺里曾在某一时期担任国民议会的首席法律演说家。但这些法律演说家直到12世纪初，他们的主要职责就是在三年的时间里，在每一年的议会上背诵三分之一的法律。这样所有的法律就都被背诵过了。所以我们有这种规模运作的口头传统，当我们谈论萨迦故事、家谱时，没有理由认为情况会有所不同。但与此同时，我们也有家族群体，我们倾向于拥有的不仅仅是一个家庭的农场，而是有大家庭，或者有你知道的在那里工作的人、从其他家族群体来那里暂住的人、作为儿童在那里被寄养的人。所以它们的规模相当大，不是核心家庭。人们普遍认为，这些萨迦故事是在傍晚时分、特别是在冬天的火炉旁讲述的，在火炉旁有一种叫做kvuldvaka或晚间守夜的传统，这些故事就是这样被一遍又一遍地讲述的。那么它们的暴力色彩呢？它们通常暴力得令人难以置信，不是吗？这是否反映了这些农场内部或为了争夺土地而展开的竞争中的真实暴力？是的，我认为这会是一种混合。我的意思是，这就像，你知道的，如果我们看看现在的荷里活
staying there from other family groups people being fostered as children there so they're quite large they're not nuclear families and the the sense seems to be that these stories these saga stories were told in the evenings around particularly the winter fires but around the fires this tradition called kvuldvaka or evening wake where these stories are told and retold. What about the violence of them? They're incredibly violent often aren't they and is that reflecting a genuine violence in a competition within these farms or for land or what? Yeah I think it's going to be a mixture I mean it's like you know if we if we look at Hollywood
电影，上帝保佑，它们可没有反映正常水平的暴力。如果这就是留给我们的全部，如果《虎胆龙威2》就是西方文明残存的唯一痕迹。完全正确。所以我怀疑，你知道的，什么才算是一个好故事？是什么构成了戏剧性？你不会真的让每个人都坐在冬天的火炉旁，听着关于索芬的故事：他花了一天时间照顾一头牛，然后去上厕所，吃了一碗粥。但另一方面，不，我的意思是，这是一个充满暴力的时代，存在着宿怨。
films nowadays I mean please god they're not reflecting normal levels of violence. If that's all that's left of us, if, yeah, Die Hard 2 is all that remains of Western civilization. Exactly. So I suspect that, you know, what makes a good story? What makes the drama? You're not really going to have everyone sitting around the winter fire and listening to the tale of Thorfinn who who spent his day looking after a cow, then went to the loo and ate a bowl of porridge. But on the other hand, no, I mean, this is a violent time and there are feuds.
许多萨迦故事都基于过去大规模的家族宿怨。我的意思是，吉尔萨迦（Njál's saga），经典之作。我的意思是，如果你想读一部萨迦，就读《吉尔萨迦》（Njal's saga），也就是被烧死的吉尔的故事。他绰号叫“被烧死的”，这说明了很多关于后来发生的事情。我想到了萨迦结束时，死亡人数大约有100人左右。所以再次强调，这不一定具有代表性，但确实存在宿怨，而且必须进行复仇和补偿。埃莉诺，还有一件事让我感到震惊，我在想我的这种感觉是否正确：尽管充满了暴力、怪异和种种元素，但在许多方面它也极其具有家庭气息
And a lot of the saga stories are based on the large-scale family feuds of the past. I mean, Njál's saga, classic. I mean, if you want to read one saga, read Nial's saga, the saga of Burnt Nial, the fact that he's nicknamed Burnt tells you a lot about what happens. I think the body count is around 100 dead by the end of the saga. So again, it's not necessarily going to be typical, but there are feuds and there are redresses that have to be done. Elena, also, one of the things that struck me, and I wonder how it struck me correctly, was that despite the violence and the strangeness and everything, it's also very kind of domestic
在许多方面。这有点像……因为这与欧洲大陆上亚瑟王传奇、但丁以及所有这些内容是同时写作的。但这是，你知道的，这里没有贵族，没有国王。这基本上是关于一群农民的故事。并且它以某种我认为对于中世纪基督教文学来说相当独特的方式反映了这一点。是的，它绝对是这样的。
in many ways. It's kind of, because this is being written at the same time as Arthurian romance and Dante and all that kind of stuff in continental Europe. But this is, you know, there are no aristocrats, there's no kings. This is about groups of farmers, basically. And it's reflective of that in a way that I guess is kind of unique for medieval Christian literature. Yeah, it absolutely is.
这也是它如此引人入胜的部分原因。部分原因在于它的背景，不仅是创造这些故事的背景，也是创造这些材料的背景。正如你所说，这些是家庭，这些是农耕群体。这也反映在那些把它们写下来的人身上。所以我们看到的是，哦，我不知道，例如盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰（比这早几个世纪），我们的大多数文本来源都来自修道院。所以这些材料是写在手稿室里的。所以，好吧，我们在这里和那里得到了一些不洁的诗歌和一些谜语，但对于绝大部分内容，你必须考虑到这些东西被写下来的背景，
And that's part of what makes it so interesting. Part of that is the context, not only in which these stories are being created the the material from which they're being created as you say these are these are families these are these are farming groups um it's also reflected in the sort of people who are writing them down so what we're seeing oh i don't know for example anglo-saxon england you know a few centuries earlier most of our textual sources come from the monasteries so it's material that's written down in the scriptoria and so okay we get a few dirty poems here and there and a few riddles but for the most part you've got to think that the context in which these things are being written down
进而形成了一种透镜，通过它我们得以审视那个社会中曾经存在的东西，因为这是人们选择在中世纪冰岛记录下来的内容。许多萨迦不仅在农庄里被口耳相传，而且还被写在农庄里。虽然有一些修道院和手稿室，人们在那里写作，但正如你所说，这是一个阶级划分没有那么严明的社会——它仍然是有阶层的，但阶级划分要少得多。到了13世纪，权力确实集中在六个（大致来说）主要家族手中。我们谈论的是一个充满内战和大量流血事件的背景。
then creates a lens through which we are viewing what existed in that society because it's it's what people choose to record in medieval iceland a lot of these sagas are not only being told on the farmsteads, but written down on the farmsteads. There are some monasteries and there are scriptoria and people are writing there. But exactly as you say, it's a much less, it is still stratified, but it's a much less stratified society. And you do end up by the 13th century with power concentrated in the hands of six, you know, six, broadly speaking, major families. And we're talking about a context of civil war and an awful lot of bloodshed.
但事实是，这些都是故事。这些是由冰岛人写下的萨迦，通常是在他们自己的农庄里为冰岛人写的。以冰岛人的萨迦为例，它们写的字面意思就是冰岛人。所以，是的，这是家庭剧。你还说过，这些萨迦被写下来的时期，正是挪威的影响力日益增长、冰岛的独立受到威胁的时期。所以这大概也是它们被写作的背景的一部分，以及它们所涉及的主题的背景的一部分？完全正确，非常强烈地影响着。
But the fact is that these are stories. These are sagas written down by Icelanders, often on their farms for Icelanders. And in the case of the sagas of Icelanders, literally about Icelanders. So yeah, it's the domestic dramas. And you said as well that the time when these sagas are being written down is a period when Norwegian influence is growing and growing, and Iceland's independence is coming under threat. So that presumably is also part of the context for why they're being written and the way in the subjects that they cover exactly very strongly so so yeah by the 13th century some from around 1220 to 1264 we have this period of really really nasty civil war snorri sturtleson you know author of many king sagas and author of
所以，是的，到了13世纪，大约从1220年到1264年，我们迎来了这段非常非常残酷的内战时期。斯诺里·斯图鲁松，你知道的，许多国王萨迦的作者，也是
um the prose edda is is a real mover and shaker in the civil war and it kills him because he, like so many prominent Icelanders that time, becomes the vassal of the Norwegian king or the Norwegian jarls who are co-ruling with the king at that point. written down they're written down at a time when the world is changing and people need to define their identity in opposition to this new order that is gradually encroaching on what they knew and so yeah by the time we get to the end of the 13th century well way before the time we get to the end of the 13th century um the the commonwealth the the independent first centuries of Icelandic settlement culture has come to an end and Norway is very much in control. Well, that's the perfect point on which to end because we've gone on for almost an hour.
《散文埃达》的作者，是内战中的一个真正的活跃人物。这害死了他，因为他和当时许多杰出的冰岛人一样，成为了挪威国王或当时与国王共治的挪威伯爵的封臣。被写下来，它们是在世界正在改变、人们需要界定自己的身份以对抗这种逐渐侵蚀他们所知的新秩序的时期被写下来的。所以，是的，当我们到达13世纪末时——早在13世纪末之前——
Eleanor, that's brilliant. But before you go, tell us two things. One, tell us the one saga that everybody listening to this should read. And secondly, you can do it much better than me. You can tell them about your book and your brilliant book about the world of the uh the world of the vikings so so go on go for it one saga that's that's genuinely difficult i'm gonna i'm gonna go for niel saga it's a it's a classic but it's incredibly it's tragic it's complicated it's got
联邦，即冰岛定居文化独立的最初几个世纪已经结束，挪威在很大程度上控制了局面。嗯，这是结束对话的完美时机，因为我们已经聊了快一个小时了。
beautiful relationships between the two central male characters. It's got a lot of very strong female characters. It's got supernatural elements. It's got politics. It's got the conversion in the middle for Tom. You know, it's got everything. I would say, though, and this is true of most sagas, one caveat. Sometimes it's necessary to get through the first chapters, which can be a little dense and very much full of genealogy. So don't give up. You know, it does get better. If you want shorter ones,
埃莉诺，这太精彩了。但在你离开之前，请告诉我们两件事。第一，告诉大家所有听这个节目的人都应该读的一部萨迦。第二，你可以比我做得更好。你可以向大家介绍你的书，你关于……的书，关于维京人世界的精彩著作。所以，说吧，尽管说吧！一部萨迦——这真的很难。我选《吉尔萨迦》。这是一部经典，但它非常不可思议、悲剧、复杂，它拥有
I go for the Outlaw Sagas, the Saga of Gísli, the Saga of Grettir. They're more character studies of individuals and they're absolutely beautiful. Beyond the Northlands, it's the world beyond Iceland, but told through the eyes
两个核心男性角色之间美好的关系。它有许多非常强大的女性角色。它有超自然元素。它有政治。中间还有汤姆最喜欢的皈依情节。你知道的，它应有尽有。不过我要说的是，对于大多数萨迦来说，有一个注意事项：有时你必须硬着头皮读完前几章，这些章节可能会有点枯燥，而且充斥着家谱。所以不要放弃。你知道的，后面会变好看的。如果你想要更短的，
of these later medieval storytelling Icelanders. So it's how this far-travelling culture, they go north to Arctic Scandinavia, they meet, there's the people they meet there, it's the Saumi, the nomads, the trolls, the giants often. They go east down the Russian waterways, they end up in Byzantium,
我选《亡命徒萨迦》（Outlaw Sagas），《吉斯拉萨迦》（Saga of Gísli）、《格雷蒂尔萨迦》（Saga of Grettir）。它们更像是对个人的性格研究，而且绝对美妙绝伦。《北境之外》（Beyond the Northlands）讲的是冰岛以外的世界，但透过这些中世纪后期的冰岛讲故事之人的眼睛来讲述。所以这是关于这个远行文化的故事：他们向北去往北极斯堪的那维亚，他们与那里的人相遇，比如萨米人、游牧民族、还有巨魔和巨人。他们向东顺着俄罗斯的水道前行，最终到达拜占庭，
they end up on pilgrimage to Rome and the Holy Land. And then, yeah, from the south, it's heading west out to Greenland, out to North America. So it's the history of the Viking world in its broad, global, interconnected sense, but it's also the stories that these people brought back, how these stories got transmitted
他们前往罗马和圣地朝圣。然后，是的，从南方出发，向西前往格陵兰岛，前往北美洲。所以这是维京世界在其广泛的、全球化的、相互关联的意义上的历史，但它也是这些人带回来的故事，这些故事是如何在几个世纪中流传下来的，它们是如何最终来到冰岛的，以及人类在需要想象世界及其自身在其中的位置时会做些什么，其中还有大量的龙和巨魔。这真的是一本太棒的书，对……的描绘如此精彩。我认为这是唯一在四大洲杀死过人的古代民族。哦，多大的成就啊，虽然我不敢确定自己说得对不对。但同时，我也想感谢你在只睡了三个小时的情况下完成这期节目，非常感谢你。谢谢大家的收听，我们很快就会再见，再见，再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前收听、无广告收听
over the centuries how they ended up in Iceland and what humans do when they when they need to imagine the world and their place within it and an awful lot of of dragons and trolls too it's such it's such a great book and it's such a wonderful portrayal of I think the only ancient people to have killed people on four continents oh what an achievement i'm not sure i'm right but but and also i would like to thank you for doing this on three hours sleep so thank you so much um thank you everyone for listening and we will see you again very soon bye-bye bye-bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要访问我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。